we were on the bus headed to the airport
and Becky comes back with like all this
cash and she just starts throwing it on
the bus and so we're like this is
probably the first time we've ever boxed
out because they do not box out we tried
but we did we were busting people like
everywhere I was like oh she we were
grabbing money and I turned I look and
Jackie young probably the quietest
person in the WNBA has she's like
Banning these dollar bills like 100
bills like hey and I was just like oh my
God we really won a championship like
that was the moment where I'm like oh
Jackie's like lit and I don't think
anybody really knows that but we were
stumping on the bus people crawling on
the like on our bus like get the
hundreds get the hundreds so yeah that
was a big one oh it was 100. it was a
big money I was thinking it was one blue
face we were stumping on dollar bills I
said come on honey who won a hundred
dollar bill Benjamin yeah Benji come on
I was getting every Benji on that bus I
promise you